watch you 73
oh yeah
who's it what happened
[Music]
out of 74. we're alive
without a 73.
put us in the area
he's shooting
all right
system is saying that he was tied up at
and then he escaped
what's going on someone shooting yeah
all right no no one's ever guns or
anything
that's it that's my license plate number
we're gonna pass you down real quick all
right
we'll come talk to you all right
I got a 74. uh we have a victim here no
suspect no gun
he is real um zip ties on his hand he
said he broke free
we're talking him now
all right what's going on man you all
right yeah I went to a service Hall my
handyman I run to my own business I went
to a service Hall they helped this guy
out there I was in the fast way and I
and he works he goes to the gym with me
I know where he works ain't worth the
swag a lot I know his address is
refrigerator and when I got downstairs
if another dude came out they had guns
on me and they robbed me I mean they
tied me up they had they had plastic lay
on the ground like they were gonna kill
me and they asked me about some money so
they put this on my face they get me in
my van and they bring me over here they
turn the location up on my phone one of
the guys is in back with me and we're
looking for the car go
where'd the car go it was parked this
way and I ran all the way down here
what kind of car was it it's my van it's
a